pasamos a hablar ahora con nuestro
primer invitado del día la reforma de
las pensiones el poder adquisitivo el
reto de la inmigración estos fueron
algunos de los grandes puntos de
fricción entre los dos candidatos a la
presidencia francesa hablamos por
supuesto el candidato presidente manuel
macro y marine lepén ambos se
enfrentarán el próximo domingo 24 abril
en lo que será esta segunda vuelta de
las elecciones presidenciales para saber
finalmente quién se queda con el palacio
del elíseo por eso quiero saludar en
este momento a florian las farc él es ex
consejero del vocero del gobierno
francés del año 2015 al año 2017 gracias
figuran por estar con nosotros aquí en
directo américa de france 24 es un gusto
para nosotros también nos acompaña como
siempre nuestra periodista rosa pérez
masdéu quien ha hecho también todo un
análisis y lo que han sido estas
elecciones rosas gracias también por
estar aquí y acompañarnos en esta
primera entrevista florian le preguntó
sobre el balance lo que vimos ayer en
este último cara cara y el único además
este debate presidencial francés
sí muy buenos días pues primero hay que
decir que este debate ya es una
tradición en la segunda vuelta siempre
se da nunca ha cambiado la tendencia en
la última recta en los hombres nunca
cambia eso entonces no es un debate que
va a cambiar toda la campaña
podemos decir que como lo hemos visto
durante la campaña no hubo un interés
muy alto es el debate que menos ha
tenido el público
porque claramente fue una repetición del
debate de 2017 un debate que ya habíamos
visto con los mismos antagonistas
es decir manuel macro de presidente
saliendo y la candidata de extrema
derecha imagino que no entonces cada uno
tenía una estrategia un poco distinta es
decir que imagino bien ella tenía que
borrar un poco su imagen de dejada en
2017 que fue un debate mediocre para
ella no estaba preparada no conocía muy
bien lo de los desafíos del país ni los
datos claves entonces su plan estación
tenía que corregirse como outsider
y tenía como objetivo de convencer de su
actitud demostraron un programa que
escribir y sobre todo movilizar para la
segunda vuelta porque ella necesita la
movilización de un electorado mucho más
amplio para ganar en este domingo para
macro eso es muy distinto porque él como
como favorito tenía todo que perder
entonces la idea para él en este tipo de
debate es evitar cualquier error de
comunicación en este caso es evitar
detener la postura de un profesor
quedaría un poco la elección a su
opositora o tener un carácter un
comportamiento un poco arrogante lo que
le fue reprochado durante muchos meses y
además durante la crisis de los chalecos
amarillos o no perder la calma en este
sentido yo creo que y manuel macro no
hizo un mejor debate que imaginó el pen
marine le pen fue mejor preparada que en
2017 pero no creo que fue suficiente
para lograr tener la victoria este
domingo
el único sondeo que ha salido después de
este debate demuestra que macro no ha
convencido un
59% de la población mientras que un solo
39% de la población para martín erpen
florian y para poder profundizar un poco
en cada cuestión dentro del tiempo que
tenemos empecemos por cuáles se fueron
los puntos débiles donde fallo cada uno
de los candidatos si nos puede hacer una
síntesis de cuáles fueron las
acusaciones que no pudieron responder
uno y otro
sí pues primero para macro no quiere fue
reprochado una vez más es su
comportamiento un poco profesor a su
comportamiento en tu arrogante eso es lo
que se pudo ver durante todo el debate
pero fue claramente el que mejor estaba
preparado claro porque es el presidente
está el manejo del país el debate fue
dividido en varios temas entonces el
primer tema fue el poder adquisitivo en
un tiempo de inflación en francia
normalmente este tema hubiera tenido que
servir mucho más a marín lópez mientras
que amagaron con su con su balance era
un poco más complicado el hecho es que
al final nos dimos cuenta que imagine
los ven con su preparación un poco
menor nos dimos cuenta que ella no
conocía muy bien las cifras claves para
este debate confundió por ejemplo las
cifras de la deuda cover no está lista
con sus propias propuestas en cuanto al
aumento salarial oa las ayudas sociales
a la población mientras que macro con un
programa que era un poco realista ha
ganado punto en este debate el el
segundo tema que para mí fue el más
importante fue el tema internacional y
ahí claramente era el punto débil de ma
jin joven que fue acusada de sus
conexiones de sus enlaces con putin que
son numerosas que ya ha negado y de
hecho durante este debate hay mintiendo
por ejemplo sobre los votos de sus
diputados europeos de su grupo de su
partido de extrema derecha los cuales
todos se habían opuestos a cualquier
sanciones a rusia y ya negó este este
pasaje el punto débil de los dos yo
diría que es sobre el tema de ecología
claramente y macro no tenía mucho que
defender en el tema de ecología pero él
tenía un objetivo una meta psicológica
dentro en el marco de la convención con
los objetivos clima mucho más amplios y
mucho más realistas que los demás y
noten que una vez más perdió puntos en
este debate
de ámbito de ecología y florian y como
explica lo que comentaba en la primera
parte de su respuesta que marín no
estaba preparada no tenía todos los
datos para hablar de poder adquisitivo
mientras que este ha sido el centro de
la campaña y se ha hablado mucho de que
ya lleva desde 2017 preparándose no este
nuevo cara a cara para no hacer el mismo
papel que hace cinco años claro y
florian yo ahí también te agrego rosa sí
con todo este contexto es ya casi
imposible que marín le pueden pegar
pueda repuntar digamos que estas
elecciones también pueden estar ya
cantadas de una posible victoria para el
candidato presidente
bueno sobre la primera pregunta yo creo
que ella como tiene una postura un poco
populista y no tiene las cifras de
financiamiento de sus cafeterías sus
diferentes reformas entonces por ahí por
ejemplo tenía como propósito de bajar
las tasas de los productos de permite de
primera necesidad pero sin darse cuenta
que esta reforma por ejemplo podría
tanto funcionar para la gente es un poco
más pobre como a los ricos porque está
este tipo de tasa está pagada para todos
lo que muy bien y ha demostrado macrón
por ejemplo también ella pensaba que
ella podía imponer el sueldo mínimo a
toda la gente e imponiendo eso a los
patrones de las empresas es más
complicado que eso entonces ella tiene
reformas demasiadas simples para ser
implementadas en francia y en cuanto a
la posibilidad de marginal vende ganar
claramente en todos los sondeos dan
como el próximo presidente
este domingo todos los sondeos lo
posicionan entre un 51 y 56 por ciento
pero no todo está hecho imagino que él
puede ganar pero bajo condiciones son
poco específicas que voy a intentar
explicarles es que en francia la
elección presidencia seguirá con 50 por
ciento de los votos expresos más uno por
ejemplo estos votos expresos varían
según la participación segundos votos
blancos y la población por ejemplo se
necesitaron 15.5 millones de votos para
ser elegidos en
1988 18 millones en 2007 el 15.7 en 2017
si tomamos estas cifras si se amplifica
un poco la ausencia en el voto al 30 por
ciento y un 12 por ciento no más de los
votos en blanco un poquito más que la
elección precedente entonces se
necesitarían solamente 13.3 millones de
votos para hacer el presidente este
domingo porque yo hablo de esta cifra es
muy importante es que margen del pena
beneficiar a cuánto está con su propio
electorado que están 9 millones a los
cuales se van a sumar los votos del
candidato de ese muro y de repente no
llegamos entonces al 11 millones de
votos y para llegar a ese punto 3
millones de votos es posible con un 25
por ciento de los votos de candidato de
la izquierda radical más del 25 por
ciento de la candidata de la derecha
moderada y allí llegaríamos a éste 13.3
millones para ser elegido presidente
entonces no es un escenario imposible el
problema con la extrema derecha es que
se sabe cómo puede ganar el poder la
gana con una participación de vida la
gana con una insatisfacción social o una
debilidad de las instituciones con
cantantes o políticos valores pero nunca
se sabe cómo devuelve el poder lo vimos
últimamente con trump y posiblemente con
el bolsón
precisamente a esto que comentaba esta
necesidad de conseguir parte de los
votos de la izquierda que se ha quedado
sin representación en esta segunda
vuelta que gestos hicieron tanto uno
como otro candidato para acercarse no al
electorado de izquierdas
bueno eso fue un poco el objetivo
claramente de esta semana
emanuel macu ha citado por ejemplo
londres que es la figura principal de la
izquierda y ha suavizado un poco sus
propuestas e incluso la propuesta que
tenía para la jubilación por quien
quiere imponer por ejemplo la
publicación a 65 años y ha dejado un
poco la puerta abierta diciendo de que
esto se iba a dar con concertación con
los sindicatos y que también podría ser
un poco menos y que se podría renegociar
en unos años entonces son señales hacia
el electorado de izquierda que
posiblemente tendría un aspecto un poco
más social una pierna izquierda un poco
más reforzada durante es un kicker a
todo lo que había faltado durante estos
cinco últimos años para marín open es un
poco distinto porque marín el bne
claramente estaba reduciendo el mismo
electorado que yo era mayor porque ya
tenía claramente un programa que era muy
social es una de las partes fuertes de
mis campaña entonces con más servicios
públicos más presencia del estado y
sobre todo más presencia del estado en
el mundo rural donde ella tiene un
electorado que es muy fuerte la cosa es
que ahora yo no sé si realmente el
pueblo de izquierda está listo
totalmente para votar para uno o el otro
una fue una parte muy importante un 30
por ciento más o menos aunque está
disminuyendo y prefiere votar ni por
macro ni por marín lo que ven
primero porque macro no representa el
neoliberalismo y segundo porque
imagínate la de planeta en la extrema
derecha eso para mí yo creo que para la
izquierda es un peligro claro porque una
suma de todas estas ausencias
individuales puede conllevar a un
desastre colectivo para el pueblo de
izquierda